assalamualaikum warahmatullah get here
to bonuses their friends hope you got to
do it well min around so we will click
another hood you got too much
I think I'd know for five days ago I
released a video I came across a video
where drifting in concert is singing to
four girls hey yo you for girls out to
you there you got this hot scarf on
wedlock take it off blah blah blah blah
so one is a horribly Michelle reminder I
did a bit of research but to me what it
seemed like a zymogen beam it seemed
like to me that he must have been
speaking to a job yet because he faints
cough I'm thinking why would rape find a
person where enormous cough abnormal in
a concept white most likely a polymath
Nina
Scott is head Scott ready for okay I've
known that's my assumption however
besides the point when I did the video
and I looked into the comment section
video I saw a lot of fathers and sisters
commenting claim that they were there
that day so I thought besides the point
I don't know evident if you say that
your system but besides the point the
point was that I wanted to address the
citizen robert who attended it that was
the main point so I did a video and in
my view I specifically said and that's
what you for October my views always
clarify here is that I never said drink
when and said in a racist way you take
image of all lab you know I don't have
any job you know liberate yourself or in
a in a in a prejudiced way towards I
never mentioned that don't find a plane
like I wasn't talking about racial what
he does it was about the Woodman's
and who pretended that so this is was
perfectly what I meant so we are
clarified my motto
so to me it seems like Drake what will
catch his attention is okay like what
will seem abnormal to him is like why
somebody got a scar from yet I already
know okay she's a Muslim or not to me
assume that that besides the point when
I was going to the comment section I
actually saw this is in hijab actually
seeing that they was there that day yeah
so that's the reason why I'm doing this
video right now guys did you see the
photo absolutely says besides the point
right besides the point if we said that
sorta stuff or not that's beside the
point
my main concern was for the board and
sisters attending there that was on it
so I just wanted to
like this because graces yes so Jason's
last night made a post saying that he's
sincerely saying that he is not racist
he did not say in that way and it was
not towards this stuff okay welcome to
clarify the point nobody I never seen no
[ __ ] way shape or form sense but I feel
in that way I did like I said before it
doesn't matter if you can't assist or
not I was home person is about to
attending that so the time it carbon is
what okay that's good
you know what in this evil individual is
this I don't know that that yes I would
know him and I'm sure his reply wasn't
for me
yes he was talking to those because
there's a lot this might beside my video
there's other kids out loud claiming
about claiming and making it see like he
was racist like he said in a racist way
and he said it in a like prejudiced way
and because of all the things that going
around them Donald Trump etc it seems
like that but that is not the case so I
don't think he was referring to me in
terms of those individuals spreading
these rumors that he told the movie ago
in a racist man I never said no such
thing so the thing is but however my
point is to the most important official
because you guys are following him and
need understand something right it was
really funny is that you know I can't
blame him and say hey I do this is way
of life he can do that has the freedom
to do that i conversation a why are you
doing it but to the move our brothers
and sisters i concede you decide no
that's wrong like why are you doing that
you see I'm trying to say so another
funny thing is that since pocket
violence just clarify this yet hope you
guys have understood and not the funny
thing is that when I was going to the
comment section one drink
what in his voice boxes into a class -
point it's funny that he was saying and
there was people comment containing
[ __ ] traitor
thank you people here are handling our
pleases Allah that your princess you've
clarified your point across that you
didn't mean it like that
you know I'm going to still listen to
your music oh wow
let's see you can you imagine I get you
want you didn't stop listening to this
music because it's a sin
you stop listening to music because you
feel something
yes please personally attached to you so
you're not stopped listening to it for
the sake of Allah for businesses you
should have been in that environment
what is it maybe yet you stopped
listening to because we felt offended of
something he said and now that he
clarified 11 delay last I can listen to
you now again
come on guys let's be real here yet you
need understand you're following him yep
he's for example let's say misguided for
example yet he's not me either he does
know the truth
yes you have a follow him yet and
musically the handiwork of Shaitaan so
you guys go into this environment you're
following him you're gonna end up being
described it from imagine is you're
gonna end up being this guidance due to
him doing things out of misguidance
imagine he accepts Islam and all the
things that he's been doing here a
plentiful almost want Allah forgive him
if it isn't it doesn't come that you
guys are going to end up being misguided
to what he did without intentionally and
you can't go to go to waste we can be
you might die off on this kind of damn
favorite song because wanting to sort of
in the environment did not lose it etc
blocks so I'm just trying to tell me
that look
yes stop listening to Dre yes not
because he's a evil guy yeah I don't
know if you don't know but because what
you doing is the sin right that's got
nothing to do with it it that'll fit you
before we just mutton it should
understand that it's a sin and let's try
to abstain from that so guys over
clarify this and please do send this the
Drake maybe you'll be watching this you
know another said before in no way shape
or form I said he was been pretty slow
movement it will be racist it won't be
tied the point I love to do it my
publisher said Muslims once again I
repeat them again please do share this
was great I hope I was a part of
apologized rate and show them the true
path of Islam the wonderful world of
mighty worshipping him in and I'm alone
and understanding that all praises and
glory come to the creator of the heavens
and the earth for anything that he has
given us I hope everyone gets guided to
the Quran in surah so about it guys
bekata have a diesel
excuse me I have a beautiful game
elephants and everything one is that
gender anomaly for whatever the way
better get
you